bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
pour ce nouveau les binaires le numéro 9
aujourd'hui nous allons aborder les
graphiques unis et vivent avec
jean-claude 2 et en fait on savoir la
poursuite de ce plan va aborder la
semaine dernière avec j'ai plein de
j'espère que vous allez bien
je sais qu'une partie d'entre vous va
suivre en direct une autre partie regard
en différé surtout n'hésitez pas à
revenir et puis si vous avez des
problèmes sur des graphiques que vous
faites des questions qui émergent
mettez de côté avec un exemple concret
et reproductive pour notre prochaine
session évacuées alors comme à chaque
fois je vous propose que l'on passe en
écran clame donc veiller à la je suis
sûr que je viens doré est idiot et puis
on va prendre la voie des habitudes
comme à chaque fois de faire un nouveau
projet les projets ils sont importants
parce que quand on apporte nos données
n'oubliez pas on est toujours sur le
chemin relatifs au projet alors pour
rappel pour faire un nouveau projet vous
cliquez sur projet tout en haut à droite
on va faire nouveaux projets quelques
secondes
comme je fais du stream par nature un
peu plus lent que d'habitude miou
directory new project on va l'appeler
nous r aujourd'hui c'est le 9 on va se
mettre dans mon répertoire mes documents
au et donc je vais faire créer au projet
m
aujourd'hui on va revenir sur sur les
bases de ggp lot de et on allait
commencer à aborder hier avec différents
types de graphiques que l'on peut faire
la part entre cette dernière et là on va
revenir plus spécifiquement sur la
plupart des graphiques qui se réalise en
b variés et on va recommencer en parle
plus classique quand on a deux variables
quand on va du coup devenir une variable
numérique
en premier je vais faire un nouveau
script pour y mettre le code du jour
et première chose on va charger du coup
le tailles diverses qu'il est peu chargé
entre autres ggp lot 2 pour rappel
lorsque l'on charge le teil diverses en
mémoire sa vos charges
j'ai eu plein de petits bonne taille
d'hier pour huila for cats une guerre
d'hier et du bio ne fait pas attention
ici au petit 9000 ans et jusque sur mon
pc cette semaine pour j'ai dit j'ai dû
faire des tests avec la machine
développement déjà pelote 2 mais le code
qu'on va voir aujourd'hui on fonctionne
tout aussi bien pour la version de base
que pour la version de développement
et puis je vais charger en mémoire
christiane r on est maintenant habituée
à bressols bac 10 mg et surtout le jeu
de données
[Musique]
hdv 2003 et puis je veux aussi chargé un
deuxième jeu de données donc en
chargeant jti se marie on aura accès à
un deuxième jaune et qui est le jeu de
données
waouh et pour pouvoir les regarder
on va charger du coup le package de la
belle alors juste pour se remettre en
aimant rapidement on va faire un look
fort pour rappel le pouvoir et d'une
fonction de la bndes et donc on va
regarder
hdv 2003
on ne trouve pas parce que c'est par là
que vous l'avez dit cissé en attaque je
dois faire tout simplement je re exécute
tout ça pour être sûr que tout est bien
chargé en mémoire et on va refaire notre
commande hd2000 trois enfants donc pour
rappel hdv 2003 ce sont des données
issues de l'enquêté histoires de vie
réalisée par l'insee en 2003 en france
et on a un nombre de variables dont
l'âge qui econnaît de manière continue
dans les autres variables codé manière
continue nous avons frère-soeur qui
co-détient en entier et nous avons aussi
leur tv qui donc le nombre moyen
d'heures passées devant des visions
chaque jour une série de ballades de
type wii non sport cinéma bricolage
cuisine elle chasse lecture bd à broc
c'est la pratique de certaines activités
qui sont codées seconde facteurs et puis
enfin on a également le poids de la
religion par exemple ou encore le niveau
d'études ou le sexe qui sont codées en
facteur je représente l'autre je ne
donnais ketch whaou
on croyait les temps mémoire dès lors
qu'on a chargé jean se marie et si je
fais un look for dessus
donc on est ici sur un jeu de mire un
petit peu plus court ce sont des données
cliniques sur des patients atteints d'un
cancer
nous avons une variable têtu trt pour
treatments qui le traitement suivi
cody sous forme textuelle l'âge qui est
codé sous forme de nombreux numérique le
niveau donc on a un marqueur de caen
alors je sais plus que de marqueurs
biologiques il s'agit mais c'est encore
une fois une variable qui s'ils
continuent de variables quad et souffre
de facteurs qui sont le niveau
d'infection states et à un grade
et puis nous avons ensuite en fonction
du traitement est ce que il ya une
réponse positive ou pas sur la tumeur du
traitement qui a causé des souffrances
binet roulis non 1 0 donc c'est un
nombre entier et est ce que le patient
décédé sous la forme d'un zéro l'intérêt
du troll c'est que c'est un il sert pour
pas mal d exemples de jti samarie et
surtout on a des variables côté sous
différentes manières pour pouvoir sans
ressortir alors on va déjà du coup
commencer tout de suite par un premier
type de graphique c'est qu'est-ce qu'on
fait lorsque l'on à une variable
continue mon premier cas de figure nous
avons une variable continu ou par
exemple on va regarder la distribution
selon l'âge dans une enquête
hdv 2003
alors pour une variable continu une
bonne manière de pouvoir représenter les
données c'est de regarder sa
distribution et pour ça on va faire ce
qu'on appelle usuellement un histogramme
alors faisons de cette histoire g avec
jgc lot pour rappel un graphique jugé
pelote c'est tout d'abord un appel à la
fonction gg pelote sur laquelle on va
donner le jeu donné ici
hdv 2003 pour un histogramme on a juste
besoin de préciser nous faisait 6 ici ça
sera la variable âge et enfin on va
appeler la géométrie correspondante qui
la géométrie l'histogramme exécutons
cela vous avez signé un le graphique qui
s'affiche donc ce que fait ggp locks en
l'occurrence va diviser
en fait notre variable continu en
différentes petites catégories
un peu enfermé par verticale et a
ensuite va calculer le nombre
d'observations dans chacun de ses pas
reproduire liste aux tables et donc on
voit qu'une majorité des personnes
enquêtées sont plutôt entre 30 et 60 ans
on en a un petit peu moins avant 30 ans
et puis on voit que les effectifs
ensuite un diminue de manière très
rapide aux âges plus avancés
notre histogramme comme on est sur une
variable continuer et c'est bien la
plantation correct la liste en drame
c'est d'avoir du coup les barres qui se
touchent les unes par rapport aux autres
on peut contrôler le nombre de bars donc
vous avez un premier parapet qu'il
parraine bino et yves qui permet de
contrôler la largeur de chacune des
débats si je voulais avoir des bars qui
représente des classes de ce1 grand jeu
pour les 10 et bein oui et 4,5 et dans
ce cas là
vous voyez bien on allait voir plus
large pour en clébard plus visible ce
que je vais faire je vais remplir des
bas en orange et je vais surtout mettre
une couleur pour faire le con tour dans
color c'est le contour des bars fils
c'est de remplissage débat est là du
coup c'est tout de suite beaucoup plus
visible on voit bien que nous avons des
bars qui font exactement 50 ans l'argent
petit souci c'est que du coup là il nous
fait un calcul qui suit automatiquement
mais voyez ça se fait pas exactement sur
des 20 24 ans sur des 25 34 ans est donc
parfois on aimerait pouvoir contrôler
plus précisément l'endroit mettre le
premier exemple
différents cas de figure donc ce que
l'on peut faire c'est qu'au lieu de
fournir bino yves nous allons indiquer
rex pour dire exactement quels sont les
endroits où l'on souhaite pour pays
supposons que moi je souhaite couper 2
55 jusqu'à 100 ans
d'accord donc en fait je cherche à faire
une séquence qui part de 15 jusqu'à 125
je vous rappelle on à sec nous permet de
créer une séquence de nombres donc je
vais aller de 55 en partant de 15
jusqu'à cendres
et on obtient ici le découpage après
c'est peut-être pas forcément le
meilleur découpage parce que si je
refais un smiley hdv 2003 à 1 et bien
l'âge maximum 197 ont des passages
jusqu'à 100 et puis l'âge minimum 6 10 8
et là du coup on a une part qui commence
à 15 donc une manière de faire des
choses un peu plus proprement ça ça te
faire un découpage de 20 jusqu'à 95 et
si je fais ça je vais retirer du
graphique
le nombre de personnes avant l'âge de 20
ans et ce après l'ajout 95
donc en fait je veux prendre ma séquence
je vais lanka publié dans un c qui me
permet de faire une combiné des valeurs
ensemble je vais rajouter 18 ans et être
lundi 7
en faisant ça du coup ce que vous voyez
c'est qu'on a fait une petite part un
peu plus courte
ici et on a aussi une marque qui fait
que 3 de l'argent en fait avec son break
on veut faire sans aucun problème
[Musique]
des barres de largeur complètement
inégale et par exemple je préfère 20
puis à 38 allée à 50 puis à 10 à 80 on
peut tout à fait choisir des découpages
complètement différencier les uns des
autres
le graphique reste malgré tout correct
en effet ce qu'il faut retenir ici c'est
que le comptage doit tenir compte de la
largeur supposons que je veuille savoir
on va regarder la rapidement combien il
ya de personnes qui ont entre 20 et 30
ans dans le nôtre échantillons donc si
je reprends mes données donc
hdv 2003 filter je cherche donc les
personnes dont l'âge est supérieur ou
égal à la femme et qui est inférieur à
prendre et je vais compter le nom
dominent dans mon échantillon g pardon
on a découpé entre miser entre 20 et 30
dans notre chaîne ce que nous avons bien
254 personnes qui montre 20 et 30 ans
maintenant si je regarde une partie plus
large donc ses 254
on le retrouve ici maintenant si je
regarde les gens qui ont entre 30 et 50
ans 180 et si je reviens les gens qui
entre 50 et 80 ans j'en ai bien glissant
56 donc on peut tout à fait utiliser
d'ebrex pour avoir des largeurs qui ne
sont pas égales mais ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est qu'ici on ne respecte pas
la forme de l'échantillonnage
parce que du coup vous voyez mes auteurs
change la forme globale
si j'avais supprimé ici 80 voiliers
j'obtiens une fois en global qui me dit
que c'est très très haut
alors quand je reviens un bingo yves de
5 la forme elle redescend donc un
véritable histogramme normalement
doit de se doit de maintenir la forme
globale de 2 de la distribution et la
voyez sur ce graphique 1 il est perdu
parce que normalement lorsque l'on fait
un graphique qui est qui a des parts de
largeur inégale on devrait on devrait
en théorie on devrait diviser la hauteur
des lignes par la largeur des bars
puisque ce qui représentait le comptage
devraient être représentés en fonction
de la superficie non pas l'auteur des
bas ce qui est important à retenir c'est
que ce qui est censé représenter d'un
poilu statistiques quand on veut faire
une présentation graphique correct la
représentation c'est la superficie qui
devrait compter et donc pas la hauteur
des tables
alors si on retourne sur l'aide de
gérard histogramme
[Musique]
je ne crois qu'il y avait une astuce et
je m'excuse je les plains
[Musique]
vous avez en fait vous voyez c'est vous
avez quand ce qui est du nombre de
points d'accord
la densité qui nombre de points dans
chaque dans chaque pas le nombre de
coups d'observation chaque parent mais
en totale en fait et redessiné sur un et
vous avez weave qui me donne la largeur
des bas donc si je veux faire une
représentation graphique correct
normalement ce que je suis censé faire
c'est non a représenté henry grecque
le nombre d'observations mais le nombre
d'observations / la largeur des bars
donc je reprends celui ci c'est
incorrect
si je veux représenter non par la
hauteur des bardes on vous remet ça
c'est incorrect
j'ai une hauteur des bardes avec des
vagues départ de largeur inégal donc
l'implantation n'est pas pertinente ce
que je devrait représenter c'est le
nombre d'observations / la largeur de
chaque classe est donc dans ce cas là je
vais indiquer nom y donc ce que vous
voyez c'est quand on regarde le fichier
dead d'une géométrie donc là c'est la
géométrie gm histogrammes qui repose en
fait sur les statistiques qui s'appelle
stade been
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que chaque
géométrie appel par défaut une certaine
statistiques qui on peut d'ailleurs
appelé une géométrie avec une autre
statistique
et c'est cette statistique stade been
qui prend notre variable la découpe en
différentes barres et va compter nombre
d'observations ce que l'on a dans l'aide
on va nous indiquer computer de paris et
bronze donc ça ce sont les variables qui
sont calculées par la statistique bin je
reprends mon fichier de l'aide pour que
vous soyez pas perdu on voit que la
géode il sera donc la géométrie
histogramme appel par définition la
statistique bean est donc cette
statistique bean avait présenté dans le
même temps et elle calcule un certain
nombre de variables et les variables qui
sont calculées par la statistique
binh son compte le nombre d'observations
dans chacune de mes barres d'un titi
c'est le nombre d'observations mais
ramené à un total de 1 donc en fait ils
disent et par le monde total
d'observation du clébard et puis vous
avez une vive qui est la largeur de
chacune des bars alors on peut accéder à
toutes ces statistiques directement
lorsqu'on va définir y avec after stax
si je fais after stats ici de can't
j'obtiens en fait là je spécifie y est à
dire par défaut si on spécifie pas y un
jeune histogramme value affecté cette
variable quand je peux aussi me dire
manuellement comme je lé fais ici est
géré en profiter pour faire un calcul
pour dire que je veux quand tu mets
divisé à eurostat
et je vérifie ça s'appelle bien vive w
idh donc
je fais ce nouveau graphique vous voyez
comment il est très différent je
reprends le premier sans correction le
deuxième avec la correction
et donc ce que l'on obtient vg diviser
le nombre d'observations à largeur ce
que j'obtiens c'est une replantation ce
qui importe c'est la superficie
représente et c'est à dire l'argent fois
auteur et donc du coup pour une classe
qui a 10 ans donc c'est le nombre
d'individus par année dans la classe
d'âge et du coup je reproduis bien la
forme générale de ma couronne
normalement dans un bistrot grade cij
affiner encore la présentation je
pourrais faire 1 40 m et en moins 65
milieu normalement plus on change on
compte plus on va affiner le nom d'
éléments plus la forme globale de la
cour drake la même si je rajoutais un
petit 25 ici au milieu on retrouve
quelque chose qui est de plus en plus
projet donc ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
que on peut faire des histogrammes avec
des largeurs de bande inégale dans ce
cas là pour faire une représentation
graphiquement correct il faudrait non
pas représenter le nombre d'observations
et le nombre d'observations / la largeur
ce que je fais ici mais du coup retenez
que le plus simple c'est tout simplement
de faire le premier graphique avec un
minou rives et simplement on va changer
le monde
la largeur suivant le niveau de détails
que l'on veut avoir aussi je fais des
classes plus petites
par exemple 2 2 on va
qui va être un petit peu moins lisse et
vous voyez on garde la même
représentation globale si je refais le
graphique avec des classes d'âge
importante car cette montée entre 25 et
60 ans et ça redescend c'est vrai que
plus on aura d'un bingo yves petit plus
on va avoir quelque chose de faim mais
si jamais ça devient trop petit alors on
va se retrouver à probablement avec trop
d'inégalités je vous refais le tout
premier là on voit qu'il ya des ajouts
il ya des petites montées des petites
variations
donc ça c'est vraiment à vous tenir à
utiliser ce que vous ce que vous voulez
en général on va faire varier ce
paramètre bin oui jusqu'à obtenu quelque
chose qui fasse sens dans le câble ce
qu'on veut représenter sinon le
découpage par défaut reste très efficace
pour représenter une densité alors une
des questions posez c'est est ce qu'il y
à un découpage automatique en que les
histogrammes en fonction du jeu de
données il n'a pas vraiment de raison
automatique là un histogramme en fait la
seule chose sur lequel on va jouer c'est
sûr ce niveau de largeur il n'a pas
forcément de deux choses complètement
automatique alors par défaut et si on
revient sur l'aide
parce que si vous regardez bien l'aide
de la fonction binôme ils ont abîmé les
bins regardons les arguments bin oui bon
c'est la largeur de chacune des bars can
be specify la scène numérique valliot à
sa fonction
on peut éventuellement lui passer une
une fonction qui fera le calcul est
sinon on peut sinon dire un nombre total
de bach en fait par défaut ce que fait
ggp lot et la russie attend donc par
défaut ggp lot utilise un 30 bar pour
vous montrer un donc on a deux manières
de spécifier les choses soient avec
paramètres binz nous indique le nombre
de bars plomb veut et donc dans ce
cas-là automatiquement gp2 a taclé la
largeur adéquate des bars pour
représenter ou alors on indique avec
bing bible à nageurs départ il va
déterminer le monde de bain à l'usagé
retenez ces deux éléments là il fait il
est varié en fonction de votre besoin et
à retenez qu'on peut faire du coup
personnalisé à les les ans le découpage
manière assez fine mais à partir du
moment
où on utilise un découpage avec des
barres de largeur inégale il est
indispensable de représenter non pas le
nombre d'observations mais le nombre
d'observations divisé à la largeur et ça
en fait ça suffira vraiment dont la très
grande majorité des cas c'est à dire
qu'on cherche à voir c'est simplement
où sont les individus les plus où les -
où est ce qu a plus de monde on a une
autre manière de représenter sa et dans
ce cas-là a notamment si on veut oui
justement
supposons qu'on veut regarder si la
répartition par âge diffère entre entre
le sauvegarde binaire donc là je vais où
je passe tout de suite sur un des cas de
figure c'est si jamais j'ai une variable
continu et une
véritable catégorielles
supposons maintenant que l'on veut
regarder la distribution par âge en
fonction du sexe donc les hommes d'un
côté les femmes de l'autre une des
premières une des manières sable de le
faire on va faire deux histogramme côte
à côte et dans ce cas là on peut tout
simplement utiliser les facettes
donc je vais faire un gg club de
l'agenais v 2003 plus à s x égale âge
plus geum histogramme et je vais
rajouter un facettes et d'un donc je
vais mettre côte à côte
donc c'est sûr - os et donc var's de la
variable sexe pour rappel facettes grid
à une syntaxe un petit peu particulière
un pur greuze écosse a c'est une liste
de variables il payera des calculs et on
utilise du couvent ars pour les indiqué
[Musique]
c'est historiquement c'est une formule
qui était utilisé
et maintenant on fait là c'est la
nouvelle syntaxe qui recommandait donc
retenez juste que quand vous avez un
lutin vous regardez voilà c'est wars
var's qu'on se parle
donc faisons graphique voyez d'ailleurs
quand je fais le graphique 100 m
d'options j'ai un message qui arrive à
l'écran qu'il dit que stade been a été
calculée avec using baines égale petit
donc 30 et ils ne disent pickups et the
value of bin oui on peut adapter on nous
rappelle par des fours on découpe entre
en bas et en haut de spécifique pour
vous de manière plus fine
alors voyez en mettant en cause sa les
amis l'un au dessus de l'autre puisque
j'ai représenté sexe en ligne et donc du
coup j'en retrouve un graphique l'un au
dessus de l'autre
si j'ai réussi ce que je voulais
initialement qui était d'avoir côte à
côte c'est donc corse alors parfois
entre les lignes et les colonnes vous
avouerai on habite fait s'il est longée
petit même et donc le mieux pas cette
sphère à tester puis de savoir adapter
alors je reviens pour améliorer le
l'histogramme et qu'ils soient un petit
peu plus visible je vais jusqu'au
robinet en fonction de la variable sexe
donc je vais rajouter ici un fil le sexe
et on voit du coup les deux histogramme
alors ce qui se passe c est ce que je
tends d'hommes que de femmes dans mon
échantillon place qu'on va représenter
un oui quand
c'est donc c'est le nombre
d'observations
or si je fais freq de hdv 2003 sexe on
voit qu'on a mis sans une femme pour 899
homme et ça se voit sur le fait que va
grosso modo on a une plus grosse
si on faisait la surface rouge et la
surface verte
on dirait que la surface rouge des
hommes les plus petits que la surface
battait cas plus éléments qui sont là
c'est ce qui m'intéresse c'est vraiment
de savoir en quoi la distribution
diffère c'est pas tant le volume et je
me ajustés sur détail différentiel on va
représenter du coup c'est pas ce n'est
pas du coup le nombre d'individus mais
la densité donc la densité c'est quand
on ramène toute la surface qui décide
donc toute la partie 1 dessine ici dans
je dessine ici en vert on la ramène un
total de 1
si je reviens dans ce fichier ned de gm
histogramme vous voyez le dans l'est
variable calculée on a aussi densité
donc c'est l'intensité des points donc
qui est mis à l'échelle pour que le
total donc que cette surface vas y
1 donc si je remplaçais je fais le même
graphique je représente est plutôt la
densité dans ce cas là j'ai précisé la
valeur d y y
eagle after that the city
donc là j'ai donc une densité qui
représentait ce qui est important à
retenir c'est que là la surface totale
dessinée en rouge est égale à la surface
totale dessinée en bleu j'ai un des deux
côtés juste de comparer la la
distribution complète des deux des deux
groupes
on peut aussi représenter directement là
une courbe de densité en ayant recours
cette fois ci à geum d'un titi plutôt
plus j'ai un histogramme donc là vous
avez les deux groupes de densité qui ont
été faites alors elles sont toujours là
tu le fasses est le fils a un impact sur
le coup leur de remplissage est en
dessous ce que j'aimerais éventuellement
c'est plutôt colorisées mes courbes
alors j'ai plus besoin de les y est je
vais je veux pouvoir vivre de les deux
en même temps dont je retire le facettes
ce qui me permet de voir directement il
est de courbe j'ai la courbe de densité
d'accord pour les femmes et la cour de
densité pour les hommes
donc la courte densité en fait une sorte
d'histogrammes lycée si vous voulez plus
d'information vous pouvez regarder du
côté de stats bounty donc oui on vous
dit à ips move plus novices tourne donc
c'est une version lycées l'histogramme
si vous voulez plus d'information sur le
mode de calcul vous louerez ici en fait
c'est à
ça utilise un c'est un message en fait
part avec incarne l 1 identity estime
est donc vous voulez plus d'informations
vous allez regarder du côté de la
fonction densité il a à moins d'avoir
des usages vraiment avancer il n'y a pas
forcément besoin d'aller jusque là
retenez juste un c'est que c'est donc
une version avancée et si je vous
présentais les deux ensemble donc
j'apprends ministre g et rajouter dessus
le géant home dans city je vérifie joue
dans l'es20 que c'est toujours bien d'un
petit issa même variable
donc là je vous a présenté
[Musique]
les deux graphiques l'un sur l'autre
alors ce que j'aimerais ça serait
pouvoir voir on va pas faire de
remplissage avec le fil par contre on va
faire ici donc là on voit les co pas ce
que je vais faire c'est nistos g
alors soit je le passe pour en orange
je vais m alpha indian 1.5 pour le
bassin
on s'était le remplissage que je voulais
passer en orange
j'ai fait un color très près 50 c'est un
gris à 50%
là on voit ainsi les bars et on voit au
dessus à la courbe de densité voyez la
complicité c'est vraiment ces terres
sont lycéens du du c'est donc sa
population lycée l'histogramme et puis
si pour vous montrer comment est ce
qu'on peut faire varier le niveau de
lissage j'apprends fait le même afrique
et si vous retournez sur l'aide de
johnson city
vous avez donc stade d'annecy avec bdew
qui ne pas mourir qu'il honnit qui en
fait en vo au niveau de lissage alors si
on va sur des w vous avez pas nous et si
on veut fixer un niveau de bannu et pour
ceux qui connaissent sinon vous avez un
kiosque qui permet d'augmenter ou deux
de l'odyssée plus ou moins si je fais à
just égale deux jours faire le premier
graphique sont de la just et avec la
just et gardez vous voyez on lis
beaucoup plus le graphique alors que si
j'avais fait le buzz graphique avec
adjust points 5
on a quelque chose qui va être beaucoup
plus proche
encore une fois le niveau d'ajustement
c'est plutôt fonction de ce qu'on
on a besoin de faire passer comme
message et on va l'adapter petit à petit
alors tout en restant sur cette logique
un de comparaison d'une variable
quantitative en fonction d'une variable
catégorielles on a aussi une
représentation graphique assez
fréquentes qu'on appelle la boîte à
moustache
donc on va charger hdv 2003 et donc on
va comparer je vais mettre du coup cette
fois ci je vais passer en x la variable
de comparaison ces sexes on y mas
variable quantitative âge et je vais
appeler geum dans ce spot donc à ce que
vous avez ce sont des bâtards au stage
qui compare les hommes et des femmes
alors pour rappel sur la représentation
graphique de la boîte à moustache vous
avez le trait plein au milieu c'est la
médiane le rectangle représente le
premier kart il est le troisième carte
il autrement dit vous avez 50 %
l'échantillon qui vont dans votre box
pelote
ici et là on vous indique le minimum et
le maximum 25 % de l'échantillon qui ici
50% là dedans et 25% ici ça permet de
comparer visuellement de groupes là on
voit que les hommes et les femmes ont
grosso modo à peu près la distribution
par âge je pourrais aussi m'intéresser à
la même chose mais en comparant les
hommes et les femmes en fonction de la
variable sport donc je vais ajouter fils
il va sport pour acheter pour ajouter un
niveau de comparaison
donc on voit que chez les hommes ceux
qui font du sport a représenté 6 en bleu
sont plus jeunes que ceux qui ne font
pas de sport et on observe la même chose
chez les femmes
petite précision la voyez des points qui
apparaissent alors quand le
maximum là il relativement éloignées en
fait en interne atteint karting c'est à
dire que oui et ça ne veut rien a
multiplié par l'ennemi et bien contient
des points un peu aberrant vent qui sont
atypiques
ils sont représente au lieu de mettre le
maximum d'ici on va le mettre en oeuvre
a une fois et demie l'intervalle un
terreau fertile et vous aurez des points
pour vous représenter les valeurs un
petit peu un petit peu étonnante une
représentation un peu qui alors l'idée
c'est que le box pelote en même temps
c'est une augmentation très inquiet
qu'il présente pas vraiment la
distribution de la population et donc
parfois certains préfèrent ce qu'on
appelle un violin graf
alors il suffit de remplacer jeunes box
pelote à geum violin est donc dans un
vase ming graf
l'idée c'est que ce que vous avez là
c'est la coupe de densité il accordait
densité en effet la symétrie cpt donc
tels que ça représente et chacune des
formes à une guerre totale de 1
mais on voit du coup que la répartition
la discussion la population n'est pas la
même on voit bien que les jeunes le ceux
qui font du sport ici ils sont plutôt
des jeunes y est leur présence à minuit
avec l'âge
alors que ceux qui font pas de sport ils
sont peu nombreux au jeune âge et ça
augmente la réponse envoyée
c'est une confrontation un petit peu
différente qui est
la représentation sous forme de violin
je vous montre rapidement une dernier
type de représentation parce que pur
plaisir
mais certains on va aller sur un
analyseur mais certains proposent même
de faire qu'amendé graphique de pirates
alors si on va sur analysé graphique
unis vivent à l'étagé club 2 pour être à
moustache c'est ici et donc il ya un
paquet qui s'appelle gg pire à tartiner
cul sur github et qui propose en fait
une version équipée vous le voyez qui
est celle ci alors je ne sais si vous
regardez en fait l'idée c'est de
représenter les points qu'ils sont
réellement présent avec une replantation
violon et la médiane qui s'y représenter
c'est une autre manière encore c'est pas
très connu un messie pour juste pour
vous dire que sur la représentation des
dissolutions d'avoir pas mal parfois à
s'intéresser mans présenter les points
en eux-mêmes pour vous montrer
rapidement comment est-ce qu'on peut
représenter les points en eux mêmes sur
le graphique
supposons que je reprenne ce graphique
là alors je vais pas faire un si je vais
faire un color and sport donc du coup
violin soi et du blanc et je vais
représenter par dessus les points
ces jeunes pointe
alors je vous fais avec uniquement on va
faire l'accompagnement que les sexes
comparons que les sexes pourraient
vraiment envoyer là j'ai rajouté
mais point sur le graphique sauf que
tous les points ils ont la même
coordonnées en knicks et donc du coup du
coup ils se superposent les uns sur les
autres n'arrivent plus à voir forcément
ce qui se passe alors premiers éléments
je vais prendre mes points en partie
transparent parce que du coup quand y en
a peu mais ils sont ceux que les uns sur
les autres on va voir cette densité
mais ce que l'on aimerait c'est ses
pouvoirs les décalés manière aléatoire
et ça ça peut se faire avec le parler de
position je vous montre rapidement
l'aide de jeunes paint
vous voyez que la géométrie job peu
comme tout le jury tri un paramètre de
position et par défaut position galles
l'identity ça veut dire la position
par mais allons encore donné de xy
donc là on respecte vous avez la
possibilité de faire opposition légale
jitter est donc dans ce cas là ça fait
après une fonction qui s'appelle qui va
décaler les points de manière aléatoire
mais si je fais ça voyez mes points mois
décalé en aléatoire en hauteur et en
largeur pour bien représenter j' aurais
dit qu'elle aimait points en aléatoire
sur la partie l'argent c'est à dire que
du coup mais je vais les bandes mais peu
leurs positions y soient parfaitement
correcte
je vais donc appelé la fonction position
de faiseur ici et je vais vous montrer
qu est ce qu elle prend part appelle
donc la fonction position de gieter elle
permet d'ajouter un petit aléa sur la
position des points en hauteur et en
largeur et on a ce à monza match car
l'opposition
donc c'est à c'est ça une degré dahlia
qu'on va avoir
je vais indiqué m rigal 07 ne veut pas
d'aléa sur la hauteur donc ici mais mes
points sont bien représentés exactement
à la bonne hauteur
par contre si je veux que mon petit
nuage de points soit un petit peu moins
large
je vais proposer à se damner à sur la
largeur pour moins nombreux si je mets
prend 25
c'est un white l'église pardon
j'ai quelque chose de course est il faut
savoir c'était dans un graphique quand
on dévale catégorielles la distance
entre deux modalités en fait à
déconsidérer 2 1 et donc avec un wii
avec la 0,25
j'autorise à ce qu'on rajoute
aléatoirement entre + et - 0 25 autour
du point si je voulais être concentré
encore plus j'aurais pu réduire mon wild
ici et enfin dernière possibilité
possibilité ces derniers pointent encore
plus clair embêtant alpha moins
important donc là l'intérêt ici vous
voyez c'est que je j'ai ma densité mon
violin plus la densité de points et donc
quand on a beaucoup d'observations cette
densité de points n'est pas forcément
très lisible quand on a peu
d'observations ça devient plus
intéressant parce que du court
on voit là qu'on voit qu'on a tout petit
peu d'observations alors qu'il n'y a pas
une certaine densité d'observation et
donc si je devais découper on va prendre
une autre variable
[Musique]
par exemple si je prends la variable
religion dans un endroit qui s'appelle
oblige
si j'avais pris religieux ici la joie
des coûts pour beaucoup plus de
modalités et bien la joie tout de suite
que au delà de la forme globale la
gémellité où il ya peu de points
représenter il ya plus de monde alors
que nager distribution qui est calculé
sur un grand nombre d'individus alors on
va faire une petite pause pour aborder
des questions que vous
je vais essayer de les reprendre dans
l'ordre herbert se permet de faire un
skater claude sur une variable numérique
unique
la kz2 xtf par des fous d'amour ans
d'observation est ce que c'est possible
donges egypte le 2 je suis pas familier
ce graphique mais j'ai envie de vous
dire que c'est assez facile il suffit
calcul une variable de rang si je prends
hdv 2003 donc à supposer que le rendant
fichier fait sens ce qui n'est pas
toujours le cas
je peux crime varier un peu rance et
simplement je vais numérotée malines peu
1 jusqu'au nom total de lignes j'obtiens
avec l euro hdv 2003 là j'ai créé ma
variable rang et je peux faire un jet
pilot
hdv 2003 avec x qui est égale rang
israël qui m'est égal de courage d'en
faire plus es et on rajoute le jeune
par contre voilà ça fait pas forcément
sens ce qui se passe différent c'est à
dire on aimerait l'étrier dans l'eau
j'aimerais remettre de la plus petite à
la plus grande
auquel cas ça serait un petit peu
différent je vais refaire ma variable
laurent donc là je prends hdv 2003 je
vais latrille et donc cotiser arrache
donc là c'est sur la variable âge les
parages
je vais recalculé invariablement donc
cette fois ci je le fais en dit plus
donc en cas de pin à elle nous rappelle
un dandy prn dans un mythe est
équivalent de faire tout au nombre
d'observations et tout ça il faut bien
sûr que je sorte un orage river 2003 je
refais mon graphique et donc du coup là
on obtient effectivement ce type de
graphique on voit les données qui sont
triés
je ne sais plus comment s'appelle ce
graphique là il doit y avoir en fonction
pour le faire directement danger de
pelote à
[Musique]
il faudra juste faire un petit peu de
recherche
mais voilà c'est représenter du coup les
deux observée en fonction de leur rang
et je suis certain que quelqu'un s'est
déjà occupé de ça mais j'ai pas le nom
du type de graphique sous la main
j'avoue ça je ne suis pas amené vraiment
les utiliser ce genre de représentation
graphique est ce qu'il est possible à
l'intérieur des graphiques
alors oui donc les jeunes m à la fin
dans les bonus
ça se fait avec la fonction à nos textes
donc j'ai reprendre un ami graphique
[Musique]
conduit si par exemple j'ai un graphique
d'accord et donc si je regarde luc
dehaene au titre à nos têtes
ça permet du coup de rajouter mais il
faut dire où est ce qu'on veut à noter
alors si je représente qu'une partie du
pays je vais donc faire je prends mon
graphique plv rajouter 1 à noter est ce
donc à notre tête ça
voilà donc je vais de base
on va rajouter un texte passe quelques
années aux têtes on peut rajouter un
point un rectangle ce type de show donc
là ce que je vais faire je vais rajouter
un texte dont faisait appeler la
géométrie texte x je veux m j'ai vérifié
si je vais mixer gall 1 y est égal à
10h45
la belle gueule médicale dans ses pompes
et ce qu'il faut retenir là je vais
appeler la géométrie texte pour ajouter
qu'ils aient la jolie tribu permet de
dessiner le texte
la belle également des tic est donc
c'est donc la valeur des textes que je
le mette sur mon graphique et ensuite il
faut que je dise à quel endroit je veux
positionner mon graphique 45
un sable mais on y ici donc moi si vous
les voulez couvre 85 ans nathan l'auteur
et enfin la position ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que quand on est une
variable qui continue la catégorie album
ici homme est en position une femme est
en position de si je vais mettre pile au
milieu ça serait pas rendu à une agrafe
et donc là du coup vous voyez j'ai mis
une étiquette à cet endroit là donc
hanotin c'est une fonction très général
on peut aussi l'utiliser quand vous
regardez l'aide de nos têtes
vous voyez qu'on peut l'utiliser aussi
pour ajouter un segment a ajouté un
rectangle à la con il faut garder il ya
toujours pareil un bonne chose à faire
première
premier exemple je me prends l'exemple
qui m'est donnée donc ça c'est l'exemple
qui nous est donnée dans l'est de la
note est
et puis je regarde en cloud fait une
proposition texte et cigales caract y
égal à 25
ça donne ceci vous avez un deuxième
exemple ici voyez il ya une seule valeur
de y menons plusieurs valeurs de x x
vote 2 3 4 5 et voyez dans ce cas là bas
ça réunit quatre fois le texte ne va pas
répéter le 25 on va répéter le vix et de
latex quatre fois un exemple pour un
rectangle donc un rectangle est défini
dans gg pelote avec x x max y ny max est
donc là il a acquis et 2.2 donc on a
rajouté un tracteur de transparence sur
cette villa
mais vous avez un exemple le segment
donc un segment
c'est la jeune très jeune tchèque bolt
en fait vous avez x et y détermine le
début du segment et hicks and y n va fin
du second et si je prends le dernier
exemple qui donnait là c'est un putsch
en revanche plonge à je sais c'est la
manière dont on utilise un peu
représentée par exemple des intervalles
de confiance c'est à dire que on sait un
point avec qui va s'étendre
verticalement avec y migrer entretenir a
noté m et encore une fois il n'y a pas
besoin de tout savoir par coeur dès lors
qu on est en capacité de les regarder
on a retrouvé la fonction qui va nous
être utile à les regarder
l'aide de la fonction qui donne en
général des éléments utiles pour pouvoir
avancer
alors une question sur le découpage
automatique en classe histogramme on
l'avait évoqué un tout à l'heure donc le
doute puis sainte et 2d soit un nombre
de classes soit la largeur des classes
est encore une fois à part des cas
particuliers je vous invite à faire
vraiment des classes de même largeur
pour les histogrammes c'est ce qui évite
d'aborder les soucis de représentation
comment ajoute ou le polygone des
fréquences alors pareil ça c'est un
graphique que je dise pas beaucoup pour
ma part mais je crois que c'est très
poli on va vérifier ça donc nous avons
ici quant à steve jobs dans city on va
refaire un histogramme de base
ici on a un histogramme de base et je
pense que ces frais poli donc si je
gm poli
c'est celui ci on peut rajouter sur le
g1 histogramme pour bien voir les deux
si vous voyez le gm ferait pauli 1 re
ajoute j'espère qu'on puisse bien voir
les départs du polygone les mots fred
poli ça les énerve à pour augmenter la
taille jus supprimés je vais pas le
faire parce axe 1 pour 15 celle qu'ils
soient bien visibles et je vous retire
la migraine pour revenir au cas de
figure peut tout à l'heure je vais
exemple après les autres je reprends là
on a un histogramme classique blues donc
j'ai dessiné on revient on a fait
l'histogramme simple donc sur place
qu'on a c'est un angle observations
toutes mes parents le même largeur j'ai
colorer les traits hongrie 50% donc
retenait que vous avez donné à 13 00 à
gré 99 créé à 0 entre 0° 25 pour trouver
des pourcentages de clients pour des
choses plus ou moins foncé j'ai rempli
en bleu mais qu'un niveau de
transparence 27% pour voir quelque chose
de clair et j'ai dessiné par dessus le
ferais poli et donc le frac poli ça
prend tout ça trace une courbe
polygonale au centre de chacune des
classes et si je ne me trompe pas c'est
bien la question était posée sur le
nybot des fréquences certaines options
graphiques de leurs bases en argument
plainte égale fall ce qui permet
d'afficher des caractéristiques du
graphique exemple lot intervalle de
confiance des médias alors je prenais ma
les fonctions de leurs bases il faudrait
revoir en fait sur une fonctionnalité
particulière et voir comment la plus est
implémenté dans gg pilotes s'ils sont
tous ces justes et la logique et pas
forcément la même
vous pouvez voir sur des thèmes précis
et c'est une différence entre facettes
grid et facettes froid oui il ya une
différence entre façade grid et facettes
pilotes et on va le voir avec un exemple
concret
[Musique]
on va prendre celui ci alors
les deux font des facettes mais un petit
peu différemment je recolle le graphique
qu'on avait là d'où on a eu la fiq je
vais pouvoir
on va faire on va simplifier un peu tout
ça donc un simple histogramme d'accord
donc là on a l'histogramme les hommes et
les femmes et je lui disais une variable
avec plus de modalités je ne relis ge
maintenant qu'ils ont à 5
s'il prend encore 1 façade grid et que
je lui passe une variable cette variable
va là j'ai dit relire en colonne est
donc le mois de chaque unes à côté des
autres et l'intérêt c'est qu'on peut
comparer puisque toutes les échelles
sont alignées les unes par rapport aux
autres
si je fais un pas cette fois
on va là aussi faire un graphique pour
chacune des modalités de religion mais
on cherche pas forcément à être tous les
à côtés des autres ce qui va faire c'est
qui va essayer de voir comment on peut
combiner les graphiques sur les
rectangles donc là il varie mal il m'a
dit si modalités ça tient bien en sur
deux lignes trois colloques et on peut
contrôler et éventuellement le montant
total j'aurais plus capable n égale 3
les deux exemples verts historiques
si j'avais rajouté égal 3 pardon à ce
moment là je force le fait en face aux
infections pourquoi ligne et du coup
comme le bassiste vient de faire deux
colonnes alors vous voyez la différence
à l'avant va essayer de tout faire tenir
comme le facettes grid impose qu'une
même variable va être que sur une ligne
ou plus sur une colonne jamais ici rose
les là où tu l'autre là où ça peut être
intéressant à bien comprendre la
différence de logique entre les deux
c'est si jamais je veux comparer avec
deux variables différentes
si je mets rose égale var ligue face à
cris et cornes ce égale var's sexe
l'âge obtient du coup 12 graphique et
donc je compare à la fois selon la
variable une femme est selon la variable
religion si je veux faire la même chose
avec un faste cette europe
en fait je voyais donné deux variables
puisqu'il n'ya pas de séparation d'une
pelote
[Musique]
et j'aurais bien je vais bien avoir les
mêmes 12 graphique avec toutes les
combinaisons mais là il a par exemple
relevé sur trois ou quatre colonnes donc
à moi de lire ce qui est au dessus pour
régulier sommes réguliers femme l'a en
fait on fait toutes les combinaisons qui
apprend les mails les uns côte à côte et
puis on essaie de voir comment ça peut
vite et donc dans l'espace quand j'avais
fait précédent avec le facettes grid
ce qui était intéressant c'est qu'en
fixant qu'est-ce qui était en ligne qu
est ce qu était en colonne j'ai
systématiquement comparaison aux femmes
la côte à côte sur les mêmes variables
et donc quelque chose qui est
probablement plus facile à lire
en fait il ya deux questions sur la
pyramide des âges alors la pyramide des
âges c'est une bonne question
parce que c'est un moyen faire jour très
très facilement la pyramide des âges
lumier jamais cru trouver une astuce une
fois et et je crois que je vais
rechercher sur l'analyse des âges est
donc sûre et angelo dedans debazac gp
dont on peut pas directement faire d'un
coup d'un seul visage mais voilà je me
dis qu'il faut les regarder du package
djedjed charte qui va permettre deux cas
une fonction pour faire des pyramides
des âges simple et donc puis donc ces
pyramides chat en fonction dans le pack
qui djendji charts sur le plus
d'informations sur un package le mieux
c'est d'aller suis déjà voir sa fiche au
cran si je vais grand budget jean charts
à voir sa page principale donc c'est à
j'ai les sharks à ça un package est qui
qui proposait fonction et je retiens le
site web du package c'est là donc allons
son site web du package parce que
parfois on va y trouver un peu plus de
documentation donc on est sur le site de
développement jerry jones et on a ici un
lien qui nous dit qu'ils aient une page
de documentation allons-y donc on est
sur la page de documentation du package
en question
ou vous avez trouvé du coup une
progression un peu général de ce qu'on
peut y faire et la philosophie de ce
package le budget schartz c'est de faire
des graphiques un peu avant ces prêts à
l'emploi alors il ya plusieurs package
en fait tu n'as même pas mal sur
internet un peu le package qui font des
appels d ail la balle pelote
c'est à dire qu'ils vont faire des
choses très organisés et si je vais sur
référence on va pouvoir voir l'aide de
la fonction pyramide chat donc on lui
donne un jeu de données
il faut donner à x ça va être la
variable je suppose qui contient le sexe
y la variable qui contient l'âge les
couleurs des bars et là on a un exemple
avec oxea joie et donc en fait on a tout
donné
la variable taz à la variable de pardon
variables y c'est le nous on sait que ça
va être le comptage et groupe et donc du
coup de calcul pyramide des âges à
vérifier si je retourne en tournant sur
elle parce que je l'avais installé chat
c'est moi je l'avais installé pour
pouvoir tester donc je reviens sur
l'aide de piran linda charts ce qu'il
faut voir c'est que dans l'exemple ou
parle d'un jeu denis qui s'appelle pop
ch donc regardons data pch et view sur
pop ch
vous voyez à
les données sont déjà organisés c'est à
dire que c'est à vous de faire le calcul
en classe d'âge par sexe et les tags de
population c'est à vous de faire déjà en
amont on calcule un d'effectifs ça peut
se faire et des groupes bail avec des
suburbs points du bayer et une fois que
vous avez donné la pyramide des âges
vous pouvez effectivement générés
cette pyramide des âges où s'ouvre tous
et deux graphiques qui sont mises côte à
côte
de toute façon c'est compliqué à faire
ces pyramides des âges donc donc des
idées pas à creuser de ce côté-là aux
besoins
alors après cette série de questions je
vous propose de continuer notre
exploration des graphiques libye varié
avec tout ce qui va être représentation
[Musique]
de variables catégorielles et plus
spécifiquement en fait les diagrammes en
bas il reviendra peut être un petit peu
plus tard sur les gras mon point qu'on a
déjà abordé la semaine dernière les
diamants barils sont importants parce
que c'est ce qui va nous permettre à m
suite
ça va servir beaucoup ce qu'on va
représenter tout ce qui va être variable
catégorielles
alors je vous propose de changer de
fichiers et des biscuits ben jawad
on a si l'on fait le point on a quelques
variables comme tâches qui sont quatre
modalités qui sont en 3 qui ont déjà des
noms courts donc
supposons que je vais partir du fichier
word donc pour rappel les variables
catégorielles doivent être co des
projets pilotes comme des facteurs et si
vous avez des variables labellisé il
faut penser à la convertir en facteurs
comme pour les modèles
on l'a vu par la catégorie à ses côtés
en facteurs variés continue sous forme
numérique et si on a des formes à un peu
atypique on temporaire ou une valérie
côté 1 2 3 4 et qui correspond à des
modalités
par exemple une variable qui est
labellisé ont fait une progression
facteurs avant de faire nos graphiques
donc là nous avons la variable stéitsch
qui est codé sous forme de facteurs donc
je vais la représenter en x et je
m'implique anbar et donc on va appeler
jeune bach
donc de la même manière que j'ai un
histogramme faisait du comptage des
observations
j'ai un bar également aussi compté sauf
que quand on était tout à l'heure avec
nos deux verrières continue il fallait
découpé en petite classe 1a c'est ce que
faisait la stat bin là on a déjà un
découpage en catégorie et donc on ajoute
à faire le comptage par catégorie je
peux rajouter un mot graphique une
deuxième dimension et supposons que je
fasse fi légal mind voyez là donc encore
une fois par défaut mon graphique va
mettre quand on y est
si jamais j'ai plusieurs donc là comme
j'ai mis un fils avec différents groupes
les éléments vont se mettre les uns au
dessus des autres mais on va voir que le
paramètre position qu'on avait déjà vu
là ça correspond à ce qu'on appelle
position dite stack
c'est à dire qu'on va mettre chaque
morceau de barbaque chaque rectangle et
28 des autres on peut jongler avec une
position autres et notamment vous avez
la position punch cij indique position
et gallotte ch vous aurez cette fois ci
au lieu de les mettre les ans tu des
autres et moins de milles les uns à côté
des autres
et enfin troisième position intéressante
c'est s'appelle position et de films et
celle là elle va être très pertinente
pour nous parce que ça permet en fait de
nous pas représenté quand mes 2
représentait en fait en pourcentage
c'est une départs cumulés
proportionnelle donc là ce qu'on voit
c'est la proportion de grade 3 grade 2
et crade un don chacun dont chacun dans
chacune de ces catégories
et là on va avoir déjà atteint 50
d'astuces qu'on peut faire un pour
améliorer
pour améliorer tout ça d'une part à
partir d'un moment je fais imposition
d'un fils si vous regardez bien sûr la
droite j'ai zéro zéro zéro zéro et 0,25
0,50 75 1 puisque ce sont des
proportions des valeurs qui sont
comprises entre 0 et 1 qui sont
présentés ici manière brute
ce que j'aimerais ça serait plutôt de
représenter des points chantage alors
pour mettre en forme des nombres de
manière générale on va avoir recours au
package skies et je vais me permettre de
faire un petit détour par la fonction
number
même valeur c'est une fonction qui va
prendre à sa route de valeur numérique
en entrée si on va les transformer on va
voir ses différents les différentes
options qui sont son possible pour quoi
j'ai par exemple d'être sûr
voilà
en fait al interne au met et numbers est
historique mais ses notes performante en
particulier donc voyons voir
exemple j'ai un des mots continue hausse
oui on voit on va on va se refaire vous
inquiétez pas voici un exemple j'ai fait
un vecteur dicks d'accord je vous mets
dans le code ou pire retrouver vos
dettes après donc dans le bonus onda m
donc j'aimerais avec tom hicks d'accord
et dont il dit qu'il va contenir
différentes valeurs m 11.20 pour
l'instant 23 10 bet 4 5 6 points 1,02 et
un grand monde 14500 68,281 d'accord
vous avez ici x et on va les différentes
options qu'on peut avoir avec number 2 x
romaine l'aide de nos moeurs première
chose c'est ce qu'on appelle l incurie
si donc simon mann brics d'accord par
défaut il va me mettre en haut mais non
il va harmoniser le nombre de décimales
et en fait quand on ne dit rien il est
ici de deviner quel est le bon nom de
décimales à utiliser vous poser parfois
un peu aléatoire vous voyez qui met en
forme et non dans un mode dit
internationale c'est à dire un espace
pour la séparation des bouviers et le
point pour la séparation des décimales
premiers éléments on peut francisé tout
ça il ya deux choses importantes qui
sont décimales march et byggmark
décimales marque c'est le marqueur de
décimales je vais vous mettre par contre
la virgule comme en français et puis là
le big mac c'est le séparateur de
milliers par exemple j'ai promis six cas
de figure de la post rock
si je fais ça vous voyez que les
décimales sont présentés avec une bulle
et pour le 14 1568 vous avez du coup une
impression de kabal et si je veux
simplement qu'il n'y ait rien il suffit
de dire que ce soit limay guillemets
c'est la chaîne et caractères bid et
donc du coup ça va rien m vous avez
ensuite ré fixe et suffisent alors ça
permet de remettre quelque chose juste
avant ou juste après par exemple
prévenir préfixe dollars ou 1,01 dollar
avant un peu à l'américaine
il suffit x par exemple 4 pour dire
c'est des dollars canadiens si je fais
ça je rajoute du coup le symbole de
l'art avant et symboles cadre derrière
maintenant on va pouvoir jouer sur les
questions d'arrondi avec la
particularité est qu'ils nomment beurre
vous avez asthme de fonction dans air
ouvert la marque et dj les djs on
indique le nombre de décimales que l'on
veut number est un peu plus génériques
lui on a accueilli si on dit le niveau
avait atteint si je mets un j'arrondis à
1 donc pas de chiffres
si je mets pour
0,01 j'arrondis à 0 001 donc jard
anglais pour archives après la bulle
mais on peut mettre des choses plus fine
je pourrais dire que je veux arrondir
aux quarts et donc si je mets 0.25
j'arrondis à 0.25 le plus proche donc ça
veut dire car à zéro ou 0,25 0,50 à 0,75
je peux aussi y mettre un un plus grand
par exemple je veux arrondir à la
dizaine
autre donc ça c'est toute la partie a
cure ici et je vous le mets en explicite
du coup du coup vous y trouvez mieux
retourné au texte vous avez ensuite les
paramètres skieurs qui permet de
modifier de multiplier en fait les
valeurs par une autre en amont si je
fais ce qui est agaçant on va multiplier
toutes les valeurs ars et du courant
il ya juste à rajouter le suffixe % pour
avoir un chiffre en pourcent
petite précision quand on précise avec
qui mais si le hac 2006 correspond à la
valeur après multiplication là je vais
être en pourcentage avec un chiffre
après les bienvenus
fin la curée s'il peut aussi servir pour
autre chose je pourrais faire vous avez
y des valeurs très grande vous avez
d'accord et donc du coup on a peut-être
besoin de représenter cette manière plus
simple et donc ce qu'on peut faire c'est
x accus mais ici un ski et on va
utiliser par un million et en slicks
j'ai rajouté millions
vous voyez on peut tout simplement avec
number finalement c'est assez souple
pour pouvoir y placer quoi que ce soit
alors c'est là pour ça pour travailler
avec jugé pelote
il est important de bien distinguer
member et de labels number number
prendre en premier lieu une valeur de
nom va transformer et un certain nombre
de paramètres label number et c'est un
petit peu différent la belle ne meurt il
n'y a pas de x au début parce qu'elle se
renvoient la balle numbers est une
fonction qui permettrait ensuite de
faire c'est
petite correction on montre un exemple
supposons que je fais en millions et je
vais dire que c'est la belle amber et je
suis pas juste les options qui
m'intéresse regardons qu'est-ce que en
millions
c'est une fonction qu'en fait la belle
nina mumbere où il passe les paramètres
ça renvoie une fonction et c'est une
fonction qui va transformer les nombres
en donc par exemple je peux faire
maintenant en millions de ll y grotte
des biens l'indifférence number fait un
formatage label number renvoie une
fonction de transformation alors à
retenir aussi vous avez des raccourcis
comme coma et label commun dans ce qu'il
ose donc toutes ces fonctions là en fait
art de number c'est juste que leur
valeur par défaut sur un peu différent
comme à eybens et à l'américaine
c'est-à-dire les reculs comme séparateur
de milliers vous avez aussi dans ce
cadre aux la fonction père cents et la
fonction la belle personne
en fait vous avez y en a plusieurs
parce qu'en fait toutes les fonctions de
labellisation portables ont un peu
particulier la baisse de la recette
poudre d pour des valeurs donc si je
fais il ya dollars qui va avec
donc si je fais de l'art de x ça l'est
mais un nom à la particularité c'est que
vous avez une mise en forme avec des
parenthèses pour leurs négatifs comme
pour les économistes vous n'avez
quelques-unes là dedans il faut pas
hésiter à regarder tout ce qui est dans
ce qui hausse les fonctions qu'ils
pensent par la belle à bâle personne
n'avait les value aussi la belle
scientifique donc vous avez des
fonctions de labellisation la plus
générique c'est number mais vous en avez
d'autres qui sont des variations autour
au jour des présentations particulier
vous avez si rien de scientifique par
exemple
on va prendre un exemple
scientific de x ou de y
ça présente un sous la forme c'est 1 75
x 10 puissance donc voilà vous avez
différentes valeurs de mise en forme
retenez bien c'est que les fonctions la
belle entorse trop de choses on voit une
fonction dont condamne les options et ça
nous permet de générer une fonction
tandis que les eaux tandis qu and
numbers fait la transformation directe
est à retenir du coup on perd cents et
la belle personne n'est d'accord qui est
la même chose que number sauf que par
défaut ce qui est déjà pas ressembler le
suffixe pour son don krone nous en amont
des gréements barre puisque la question
était ici de jeu veut afficher des
pourcentages
donc je représente notamment barré vous
l'ayez en mémoire donc là ce que je peux
modifier ses l'échelle y ce qu'ils la
semaine dernière son d'échelle pour
modifier le lien entre une esthétique
est valable on est dans le contexte
continuer la baisse soit je lui donne
des valeurs précises par exemple je veux
à dos et l'eau
kitty r là je donne directement les
valeurs de textes que je vous
rappellerai trt ou alors on peut lui
passer une fonction de mise en forme des
textes et donc par exemple j'avais passé
la même paire cents la belle paire s'est
tu vas me renvoyer une fonction de mise
en forme
par contre je vais faire une toute
petite modification je suis avant
français en français il ya un espaces
insécables avant le pousse à 9% donc
éventuellement je vais changer le
suffixe à l'espace pour cent
tout ce qu'on voit là et avec les
dernières versions de gégé posté par cas
sur les versions historiques et
réversible entre x et y
donc je peux vous faire le même
graphique d'accord sauf que je passe ce
stage on y est du coup c'est là que j'ai
dit ce que je voulais changer
bon dans les déviations de jets peloton
peut être symétrique
maintenant la question qui se pose et je
vois qu'il arrive
john's et comment est ce qu'on les
étiquettes surnom de ma fille et c'est
là où ça peut être un petit peu plus
compliqué alors on va revoir chacun donc
sur ce premier graphique d'accord on a
compté et j'aimerais pouvoir mettre dans
chacune des cases le nombre
d'observations
si on regarde on jérôme vers la
statistique qui permet de faire ce
comptage s'appelle la statistique
quand est on retient aussi donc on n'est
que pur moment les éléments sont à
l'affiché avec une position qui était la
position stack
c'est à dire pour les amis les uns
au-dessus des autres la géométrie qui
permet d'afficher du texte appellent la
géométrie gm texte si je regarde l'aide
de l'ageroute rit jaune texte pour
rappel on va le voir dans les
esthétiques qui font une esthétique
label qui indique le texte que l'anglais
affichait et enfin film regardé par
défaut la statistique utiliser ces
identités c'est à dire je ne transforme
pas les données et la position s'est
identifié je prends les valeurs de xy
qui monte voit donc pour ajouter nos
étiquettes journal graphic les yeux j'ai
dérapé germes texte en lui passant un
certain nombre de paramètres en plus
déjà il en lice c'est ce que vous
représentez je peux représenter donc il
faut que je vais être la belle et donc
je veux quand tu seras after pour rappel
acteurs stade me permet d'accéder à
l'une des variables a coulé pour que le
calcul se fasse aussi dangereux texte il
faut que je précise à gérer ce texte
d'utiliser la statistique quand
qu'est-ce qui se passe et bien ce qui se
passe c'est que c'est pas tout à fait le
résultat voulu obtenir quand on fait le
comptage pour sturridge taïwan
on va compter 13 17 et 23 pour les trois
catégories qui sont là et donc si je ne
rajoute rien d'autre io est affiché 13 à
une hauteur de 13 17 à la hauteur des 7
et 23 à l'otan de 23 du coup il faut
aussi que parce que la position par
défoncer position stack donc en fait
quand on fait un stade plein et qu'on
précise rien on va mettre la valeur de
keynes dons y est du coup les moins
représentés à cet endroit parce qu'on ne
sait pas ce en stack c'est à dire qu'on
va avec les poings les uns au-dessus des
autres ce qui se fait en dix ans
position d'un stack
alors si je fais position idéale stack
on commence déjà obtenir un peu mieux ce
que l'on souhaite c'est à dire que j'ai
bien en fait ça va créer le cumul est
donc 13 est représenté au niveau de 13
23 bat c il est représenté à la position
39-36 m3 + 13 8 8 sauf que moi ce que
j'aimerais bien cette méprise prend au
milieu de mes barça serait quand même
toujours y eut donc pour ça on va avoir
recours à position stack
donc en fait ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
que je fais position égale non la
position 3 10 mai il va chercher si une
fonction qui s'appelle position de
square mot sinon je peux acheter
directement la position et la jemaye a
indiqué un des paramètres de position
stack cv just kids ou est ce qu'on se
positionne verticalement et 0 pour
s'aligner en bas 0,5 au milieu un
montant au si je fais position stack
points
ac je me positionne au milieu de chaque
ligne du bénin
vite ici vous montrer une autre syntaxe
possible concernant à quel endroit je
mets label iaaf the state's quand la
jenny dans le sas de manière globale et
joris plus possible m dans le gm texte
alors je vais mettre sur plusieurs
lignes toutes les géométries on va
paramètres s'appelle mapping qui permet
d'indiquer des esthétiques qui ne seront
valables que pour cette géométrie
autrement dit en faisant ça j'indique
ajam texte d'utiliser after that can't
associé à la belle mais ça me permet de
pouvoir donner une géométrie qui ne
servira que pour la géométrie texte que
pour cette couche là s'en servir les
autres
j'obtiens exactement le même résultat
voyons voir maintenant comment est ce
que je peux mettre des étiquettes sur le
deuxième cas de figure qui est l afic
doges
donc là on va remettre encore une fois
le nom d'observation dont quatorze dates
car ns et gm texte alors si je ne
précise pas rien ce stade là vous aurez
forcément une erreur parce qu'il me dit
que dans le texte il ne trouve pas de
valeur quand il faut bien préciser stats
et can't sinon la valable qu'en ne sera
pas disponible pour la géométrie texte à
ce stade là comme tout à l'heure on a
nos différentes valeurs qui sont
véhiculés et elles sont positionnées bas
sur la banane a relaxé x qui voter et un
t2 t3 t4 plus par défaut y est
positionné sur can't donc même pas du
tout à l'heure
l'âme notre petit souci maintenant c'est
du co2 décalé et ça c'est lié en fait
contre en position 2 h
donc essayons de faire position égale
peuvent alors là on nous dit will not
des files il faut préciser d'une valeur
de wii donc pouvoir et l'opposition
donne je vais vous expliquer que cette
cuvée cet effet dû weave
mais sachez que par défaut utiliser
points 9
cette fois-ci mythe et mes valeurs
textuel sont bien positionnées au milieu
donné par leur petite précision à
comprendre nos bars
[Musique]
dans gm par par défaut l'ensemble des
parcs côte à côte a une valeur d 09
c'est pour ça qu'on a un petit espace
qui est entre les deux d'accord si je
change de paramètres weave par exemple
je fais un groupe de 0.75 départ sachant
que la distance entre t1 et t2 vaut un
lait par demont plus qu'une largeur
totale de 0,75 est ce qui fait qu'on a
ici un espace plus grand
si je réduis encore avec 1,05
on augmente l'espace killy a entre les
barres pour que du coup le calcul de la
position de hub se fasse correctement
dangereuse texte il faut admettre sa
pleine valeur de weave
donc je vais vous dire des deux exemples
comprend ce que ça fait donc si on ne
met rien dans les jambes a remixé par
défaut 09
il faut utiliser et ici je rajoute du
coup ici brion d'alger de galles 05 je
manie directement si je reviens sur mon
graphique ici
ce qui est pas forcément agréable c'est
que c'est la position des 17
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que par
défaut
nos étiquettes sont centrés sur le point
donc le 17 si vous voyez la forme 17
il est aligné pour le centre du texte
soit à la hauteur de 17 ans auteur et à
la position horizontale qu'on a qu'avec
l'opposition d'âge
vous avez des paramètres h juste éveil
just qui permettent de modifier cela si
je rajoute vie just soit alors je sais
jamais si c'est zéro enfin si on met un
vide juste en un
on aligne vers le haut et donc du coup
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que on prend
le haut du 17 qu'on colle au point donc
s'est alignée vélo et donc 10 et
apparaît en dessous et si vous mettez
zéro
si vous mettez 0 c'est un petit peu
différent on va être alignée juste en
vain si vous voulez en fait pouvoir
décoller un petit peu
l'astuce c'est qu'on va dire au jeune
texte sur plusieurs quotidienne dans le
mapping je vais dire que je veux m'en
fait non pas une position des points
alors à l'heure des 17 mai je rajoute
une valeur ses afters stats car nice +1
beaucoup de mamans
pardon j'oubliais le ps ici ce que je
fais beaucoup de on va le faire enfin ce
que je fais je modifie la valeur de y
le mapping sur y que pour jeunes texte
et pour gm texte jeudi que le y ça sera
quand tu +1
ce qui veut dire que là mon étiquette 17
sera dessiné en position 18 et juste au
dessus puisque je vous fais just égal 0
enfin on pourra voir une autre technique
qui serait de dire que je mets juste un
et je dessine tout
à eux
le bas ok je me souvenais plus à l'aise
comme si vous n'arrivez je fais ce stade
comme hossam kun pour - stade tantes
pour me mettre en dessous à zéro du vent
tellement plus simple pas être collé
tout à fait vous voyez en fait on peut
jongler de manière directe et régulière
pour avoir ceci reste enfin le dernier
cas de figure donc ses positions égale
file donc revenant là je suis en fils
je peux avoir
proposition fils et comme tout à l'heure
j'ai envie just un aliment verticale est
donc ici j'ai ajouté du coup mais quand
c'est le nombre d'observations
or je veux bien et c'est la question qui
nous est posée
on n'aimerait pas avoir le nombre
d'observations mais c'est à voir que
tout le pourcentage est pour avoir le
pourcentage sur un graphique en position
de la ville ce n'est pas possible de
base dans gg pelote
je vous avoue c'est un problème qui m'a
turlupiner pendant deux trois ans
j'avais trouvé des premières solutions
qui fonctionnaient mais n'étaient pas
forcément très élégante
jusqu'à ce que quelque chose de plus
simple
apparaissent et qui est aujourd'hui
stabilisé mais pas directement
accessible danger jed claude s'est
inscrite dans gg galy que j'ai gagné on
l'a déjà vu un ça nous permet de faire
pas mal de graphiques diverses et
variées et notamment dans gg galy vous
avez une nouvelle statistique qui
s'appelle stade propres alors je vous
explique pourquoi
si vous allez voir les deux jeunes
hommes de stats kranz d'accord si vous
avez regardé dans l'aide de stades quand
on vous dit qu'ils calculent deux
esthétiques
quand est propre
le problème c'est cette question de
groupwise propos je sais qu est-ce que
c'est qu'en fait ça cale qu'une
proportion au sein mal joué
supposons que j'en reparle de cet
exemple n'en est qu'au lieu de
représenter 40 jeunes qu'on présente
propres
y voyez que c'est toujours égale à pas
mal quelque chose qui est un peu pour
cliquer sur la manière dont les calculs
sont faits dans gg pelote veut mais en
fait ça c'est un panel et d'espagne
alger 2 3 4 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 secondes et
donc du coup en fait les variables sont
groupés là pour chaque valeur de t1 t2
t3 t4 et pour chaque valeur du grave on
voudrait c'est de pouvoir dire comment
se calcule le pourcentage
c'est là du coup harry une nouvelle
satire sat qui s'appelle du coup stade
propre et qui est disponible dans gg
galli donc à vous est présentée ici à
son niveau des aides
donc pour l'appeler à cette différence
est qu'on va faire sa propre stade
propres
[Musique]
va calculer une proportion et un colt
sauf qu'il va falloir qu'on dise avec
l'esthétique pareil moment la proportion
doit être calculée et donc du coup si je
fais simplement ça je vais avoir un
essai et erreur parce qu'il faut
impérativement que le bail soit spécifié
si je reviens à mon graphique
graphique avant le sable propre nous ce
qu'on veut c'est que les totaux des
pourcentages s'additionnent pour chaque
valeur de stage et donc du coup on va
indiquer légal en faisant ça nous avons
les proportions 24 ennemis 43,3 et 32,7
et c3 proportions là s'additionnent pour
faire sens et pas réussi 0 36 0 34 0 3
7e pour faire alors bien sûr là c'est
pas joliment présentés donc on va
améliorer le graphique en appliquant la
belle personne ce que je veux c'est la
belle moi cette personne ce 2e acte 1
scène rock puisque je vais pas la
fonction je vais appliquer directement
résultat et je vais préciser que messi
pour forcer un affichage avec un chiffre
après la virgule ou dans certains cas
pour alléger les graphiques un jour que
rendent régulièrement quand y'a pas
besoin de la décimale de ne pas la
mettre sur le graphique juste pour la
géographie qui avait quelque chose de
plus lisible ce qu'il faut faire c'est
qu'il faut bien comprendre ce paramètre
bail
juste pour vous montrer ce qui se passe
quand on change le bail si j'avais mis
by égale breiz j'aurais calculer des
pourcentages dont les totaux
s'additionnent sur great c'est à dire le
25 26 points 26 22 fonds 120 +30 +22 +28
font sens si on veut des pourcentages du
tout haut j'aurais mis par idk one pour
dire qu'un seul groupe
et là vous avez des pourcentages du toto
la manière dont le pourcentage calculé
est indépendant de comment vous
représentez vos données c'est vous qui
dites
expressément comment voulait représenter
vos données pour plus d'informations sur
le bail
vous pouvez aller sur le site de gégé
galli si je fais cran gg galli on va
trouver la page
j'ai des amis qui m'ont envoie sur les
sites de gg
[Musique]
si et dans les articles qui présentent
différents éléments à
vous avez stats un article il présente
des statisques ediciones courges et
gally et qui nous présente pentecôte
stade propre des choses avancent et vous
avez aussi whiting mina pour des moyens
d'avancer les cros l'a davantage de sa
propre
ici vous voyez comme ça c'est ce qu'on a
vu il intéresse et que ça marche quand
on fait des facettes
mais vous pouvez aussi faire des
propositions du toto un harnais avec les
cantonales et pourcentage de photos qui
sont présentés on peut faire un deuil
deux barons pourcentage plutôt qu'en
cash pour justement ajusté sur les
tailles et on peut faire plein de choses
plus avancé n'hésitez pas à les regarder
de ce côté là l'avantagé comme la les
calculs ils sont faits en temps réel
danger pelote et ben c'est que si je
reprends goût la fiq de tout à l'heure à
10 h
si j'en prends sous la fiq là et je
rajoute une facette facettes europe
qu'est-ce qu'on va prendre notre chance
[Musique]
comme fonction dans les données mais
tient par trt vars trt oui il en a deux
traitements et très facilement
juste en rajoutant le facettes on a
refait le même on a refait le même
graphique mais c'est pas bon pour chacun
des deux groupes et les pourcentages ses
calculs de manière automatique vous
trouverez pour ceux qui sont intéressés
parfois si on aime beaucoup d'astuces ou
en fait au lieu de passer par sa propre
en amour on crée ses propres
on fait le calcul en fait des
pourcentages en amour et ensuite quand
on appelle gbot on lui donne directement
les pourcentages
le souci c'est que du coup dès lors
qu'on veut rajouter une face il faut
refaire l'ensemble du quai voilà
il n'y a pas d'autre d'autres
commentaires pour pour ce soir le nuage
de points on l'a pas revu mais on
l'avait abordé déjà longuement la
semaine dernière avec y compris la
droite de régression linéaire il y a de
toute façon un nombre énorme de
graphiques ce que je vous invite à faire
pour vous aider à utiliser ggp lot c'est
de regarder le tchi tchi qui est dédié
si vous allez dans la manif sheets et
parmi ceux qui sont directement
disponibles vous avez dataviz jloc tout
si je clique dessus ça va lancer le
déchargement d'un document cliquez
dessus
donc ça c'est le cheat je vous invite
vraiment à l'imprimé en recto-verso
l'avoir à portée de main vous verrez il
vous rappelle les grands principes
donc l'idée c'est qu'on a des bonnes et
qui sont associés les géométries villa d
esthétique dans un système de
coordonnées
on présente toutes les gens m
la plupart des grandes géométrie ni nazi
sont pas toutes mais voyez on a des très
basique le ruban le rectangle polygone
des étiquettes et quand il les aurait
vous avez énormément de choses à trois
dimensions pour faire et puis on va
retrouver
des colonnes c'est un peu l'équivalent
djemba les boks pilotes des deux blocs
qui sont aussi encore une variation
autour du féline
des pros on va compter les points qui
superpose ça se fait avec jaune quand
les histogrammes très polis d'autres
plats dont vous avez un rappel un des
principal type de graphique et ensuite
on vous rappelle les différentes
statistiques qui sont exprimés c'est
juste un résumé mais ça nous permet de
retrouver le nom d'une fonction il ya
une fois que vous avez le nom de la
fonction vous pouvez rapidement à les
regarder mais de cette fonction-là donc
retenir quelque chose d'important le
cheat c'est vraiment à des outils
indispensable d'avoir sous la main
de toute façon les graphiques
ggp l'autre on en refera à l'avenir
parce qu'on fait à chaque fois qu'on
veut de l'analyse on a besoin de faire
des graphiques donc on y reviendra
indirectement sur ces graphiques gp2
n'hésitez pas à pratiquer c'est toujours
utile
la semaine prochaine on se retrouve pour
parler des données pondérées des plan
d'échantillonnage complexe et comment
est-ce qu'on peut analyser tout ça
correctement en ayant recours au package
sauvé et les adaptations que savard
heureux quérir notamment avec tiberi
samarie pour les statistiques
descriptives pur calcul des modèles mais
également vers hadji servait une astuce
pour arriver à faire des graphiques ggp
lettre de quelles données pondérées
d'ici là portez vous bien très bonne fin
de journée et on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau webinaire
merci à vous